look at this one uh Queen
no I was going fine
he was talking about eating Smash
Burgers and I said I would like a Smash
Burger and I said I I dare you to bring
me a Smash Burger tomorrow and obviously
he didn't oh but I was afraid of getting
grease on the Velvet I'm so sorry I was
very sorry Queen tells you to bring her
a Smash Burger really I'm just glad you
and Kate made it home from Palm Springs
I don't know I don't even know what I
know what went on during that drive
Jamie I feel like you perennially have a
good time whenever you go I do seriously
I do like I think like I want that
energy some of that Joy it just seems to
come natural you know what life is short
and precious and we're in a profession
that celebrates the Arts
at a time when we're out of covid we're
back together and if we're not
celebrating this this moment right now
what what are we doing you have won the
Golden Globe twice so you know what this
feeling is like we're nominees tonight
like what's going through their head
what are they you know what no matter
what it's a weird horse race and it's
out of your control you don't take you
don't make the decision so everybody
wants to win of course and
you know it's so it's weird but they'll
get through it it's nobody cares and at
the end
win or lose it doesn't matter we're here
celebrating the Arts your cohort Ryan
Murphy's getting a big award tonight yes
indeed and so when you think about the
magic that Ryan has made in the Lexicon
of Television for us you know what are
your thoughts about his honors
he's Brave He's a brave person he's not
afraid to push all of our Consciousness
to think differently to look at
issues with a very clear eye and a
brave eye He's a brave
Creator and
[Music]
um
his legacy will live way on Beyond him
but bravery is what I would say
and also you have a connection to Eddie
Murphy who is the assistant trading
Place one of my favorite movies ever I
mean you really like I mean you are
connected to just about everybody when
you think about Eddie being being
nominated being honored for his life's
work as well
again he's someone who has I've seen him
I've known him since he was a young guy
and 91 was traded but now he's a grown
man a father a beautiful person and a
very creative talented guy and I'm happy
for him you talked about you talk about
Legacy just a moment ago and you I love
the actors on actors who did with Colin
Farrell and you talked about like
sobriety as your legacy that was so
interesting yeah well it is I mean with
all of Show Business the greatest thing
I can do is break the cycle of addiction
in my family line and stay sober through
all of this because all of this is a
mind F and
a lot of people drink over it the
disappointment or the excitement or
whatever the attention why am I getting
whatever and I'm very proud that
choosing to live a sober life has
allowed me an incredible freedom I mean
I'm I'm more free today than I've ever
been and I'm 24 years sober I love
hearing that I love hearing that and
that's not for everybody by the way and
I'm not proselytizing saying you should
do that I'm telling you
it will be my greatest Legacy will we
see you backstage tonight perched where
you can get the best angles the best
pictures because I know you like to
celebrate he likes to take a good
picture
um you know I'm not I don't I'm not
gonna cross pollinate
um my purpose my purpose is to be here
celebrate my artists celebrate my
friends celebrate Ryan celebrate Eddie
and um
no I won't try to also get the best
picture of the night which I would
normally try to do you definitely do
foreign